[Music]
hello and welcome to our webinar with
the BBS a my name is Fumero Mensa and
I'm a second year here at the GSB and
I'm joined by two of our incoming
presidents of the BBS a as well I'm
joined by Elise in Ruth like me they're
also current students and as I mentioned
their incoming presidents for the BBS a
we'll be talking about our personal
journey to the GSB some of our career
decisions and then life after the GSB
for me and answer as many questions as
we can during this time to submit a
question all you have to do is click the
Q&A button at the bottom of your screen
we won't be talking about the admissions
process financial or financial aid if
you do have those questions we encourage
you to reach out to admissions into
financial aid to get those specific
questions answered let's begin with
introductions Elyse and Ruth can you
please start by telling us a little bit
about yourselves where you are from what
you'll be doing what you were doing
before you're coming you came to the GSB
and what you'll be doing after
graduation at least let's start with you
great thanks ooh meta hi everyone
I'm Elyse Smith I am originally from
Chicago as the meta mentioned I am in
MBA one I'm also a joint degree student
and in pursuing a master's in education
prior to getting to Stanford I was at
IBM Watson where I was developing early
iterations of Watson for education
products and leading EdTech partnerships
and more recently was that newschools
venture fund a philanthropic fund that
invests in the education space working
in their diverse leaders portfolio great
thank you
Rick how about yourself hi everybody my
name is Ruth originally from Nigeria I'm
an MBA one incoming president like foam
ed has said I started my career at Ernst
& Young where I audited several
entertainment and healthcare real estate
companies in Los Angeles but have also
spent a significant portion of my career
working in different capacities on the
African continent particularly in Kenya
and Nigeria in fin tech companies so I'm
super excited to be here and
to answer you guys questions great thank
you guys let's get started some
questions submitted by the audience well
this one's a pretty easy one
what did why did you come to Stanford
and what did she come to learn do you
want to start sure so why did I come to
Stanford I came to Stanford cuz I got in
number one but I'd always known that I
wanted to to get my MBA because I knew I
wanted to pivot my career from more
finance focused to more tech focused
like I said in my introduction I am from
Nigeria and so one of my life goals is
to help bring African owned products to
the rest of the world and I felt that
Stanford was the best place for that not
just in terms of getting your MBA like
you can at other schools but really a
hub for creativity like I've never seen
before on any other NBA campus and then
it was the second question
would you come to learn I think oh yeah
that's exactly what I learned and meet
amazing people from all over the world
which has definitely been check off the
of the checklist yeah similarly coming
to Stanford for me was because of like
offered something that no other school
did so the first it's the master's in
education joint degree program with the
MBA you can do it in two years and which
is a really positive experience and part
of why I came but also I knew I was
interested in social entrepreneurship I
knew that I wanted to be in an area
where ed reform and social justice were
part of kind of the fabric of the
environment and I think that paired with
kind of the entrepreneurial spirit the
VC spirit here in the bay was something
that I couldn't turn down yeah I think I
definitely resonate with you guys on
just the global experience for me it
also was a lot of the soft skills the
ability to do to you know hone and
invest in myself so I think that's also
a really unique thing that Stanford does
bring whether that's through
interpersonal dynamics it's also known
as touchy feely whether that's coaching
and developing others and some of our
peers I think that those are two
important things as well
[Music]
what made you I assume Ruth you're a
pretty successful person that you got
into some other schools
and same as you Elise you know I think
you guys talked about a little bit but
can we really double down on why did you
choose Stanford potentially over other
opportunities that you may have had yeah
I think I would like double touch on
what you mentioned from Etta and that I
think the Stanford program really
focuses on becoming a leader that others
want to follow that helps you take time
to think about what that means for your
leadership style and then gives you a
bunch of opportunities to practice that
and live through that and so you know
whether it's giving a low-key note where
you get to think about what's a point of
view or perspective you want to share
and then getting to give a ted-like talk
to the community I took advantage of
that opportunity this year that was
really powerful you know whether it's
taking touchy-feely getting to be a
coach and a mentor for other students or
going through leadership labs where you
know that's your first quarter you're
working with a team and kind of a squad
is what they call them and getting to
get feedback about how you come off
giving feedback to your other kind of
your peers and this really exciting kind
of collaborative environment I didn't
see that in other programs as much as an
emphasis and that was something that was
important for me knowing that I'd want
to lead my own venture in the future
yeah yeah I think for me funny you know
if I chose Stanford because I was out of
my comfort zone here I'm used to I used
to do audits so the process everything
is really laid out for you and it's up
to you just to kind of follow through
all the rules and I really felt like
here you your experience is really what
you make it because Administration
really wants to see people do as many
different types of things as possible
and I think in other schools number one
it might be easy to get lost in the
numbers and then you're just kind of
following the process that's laid out
for you but here it's really about you
know yes you can do things like lead
labs and low key notes but you can also
be working fully working on your company
and getting funded for that and be one
of many students getting funded for
really amazing things that like they're
doing I know at least as one of those
students getting funded for an amazing
company so for me knowing that the
school also focused more on the
individual and less on clusters really
spoke a lot to me because I felt like I
my experience would be different than
all other 400 students and I really felt
strongly that I would get that here
also you can't be California's weather
man so all of those things are the
reason why I chose Stanford yeah I think
Stanford has so many like niche
opportunities - yeah I think you know
for us there's so many students doing
different things from some of my
classmates who are beekeepers and
working in agriculture act like there's
just so many things that people are
doing and and especially things I never
knew before
everyone is kind of doing their own
thing yeah but able to utilize the
resources to their advantage as you guys
talked about and as you definitely do
now and I think that's that's really
unique about Stanford is you have all
the resources of the broader University
yeah while still being able to be part
of this this organization and move
forward with everyone else
so speaking of from your guys
perspective what is the Stanford
community like if someone were to ask
you what makes Stanford Stanford talk
about kind of the cultural element and
what you've experienced yeah I think I
would say one of the things I love is
this focus on kind of vulnerability and
being open and being your authentic self
it's something that I think is really
highlighted in the program talk where
students get to talk about you know 45
minutes to share whatever they want
oftentimes it's personal stories about
their lives or things that they have
thought about deeply and you're the
whole community comes out MBA ones MBA
2s and I think that and you know people
are just standing giving an ovation for
like I don't know like five minutes it
seems sometimes and I think that to me
is like such a like hallmark of the
community and I think it comes out that
in other places and just one-on-one
conversations and coffee chats you know
if someone got a coffee chat with me the
other day we were talking about media
and new media but we didn't get there
until like the last 15 minutes and for
the first 30 minutes it was just us
learning about each other getting to
know what drives us talking about having
a partner at the GSB and so I think that
to me the piece where it's like you're
not necessarily this like business
person where you're like I'm gonna get a
coffee chat to learn about finance and
like I'm gonna only talk about that it's
like we're people first and I think
that's something that's really beautiful
about the community yeah so
I love about Stanford community is
actually just the layout of the
community so we have for those who
haven't visited Stanford yet we have
classes really on one side of the street
and residential areas on the other side
of the street so it takes all of two
minutes it's again from your doorstep to
class and it's not even just about the
distance it takes to get to classes more
about the community that you have as a
first year where you're not driving
extremely far to see your classmates or
you're not if you if you're going
through something whether it's a
homework assignment or something at home
either your roommates or your or your
400 friends are there with you within a
really small radius and I think that
that just I think oh so over 95% of I
would say first years live in these
residences they're pretty nice it does
feel like a Golf Resort a lot of the
days but I also think that it helps to
create a real true sense of community
because you're not worried about
distance we do so many events in the
residences from birthdays to to bridal
showers to you name it we just hang out
together we also definitely have time to
go to the city but I think that that
part really just like creates a natural
space for people to get to know each
other like outside of what might be a
natural click in another area so for
example none of my friends friend groups
are a status quo group and I really like
that and I think that the residents has
really helped to create that yeah but
even if you don't live in the residences
you still you can still be a part of the
community yeah yeah great we have some
more questions so I think this is a
great one for us so getting a little bit
into more the pre application process
have any of you've been involved in MLT
or other permits through these school
applications and we're laughing because
animal TV was what I did so I'd only
take a second to talk about that yeah
for me personally MLT was a life-changer
coming from LA I didn't really have a
circle of of people that were
like-minded and ambitious as I was and I
think the vibe that MLT provides you
with just like amazing people of color
from
over the country I think almost 300 were
in our cohort who are who have the same
like who have as ambitious as you are
that really helped me in terms of this
whole application process I also was a
rare case where I did MLT from Africa so
it was still it was still relatively
easy for me to keep in contact with my
coach as well as my as well as well as
my MLG cohort so in terms of MLT really
being just like your you feel like
you're in the trenches together with
other people to give you recommendations
together you're reading each other's
essays I know one of my classmates
helped me read my essay for Stanford we
we're at each other's I say we both got
in so MLC was really amazing I know
there are other programs like Forte for
women and things like that but those
things really helped me feel like I had
a community even before I got to
Stanford and I still have that community
today yeah
I think for me I'm LT was he was really
helpful and valuable but I think because
I wasn't confident that I wanted to go
to business school and it was still
something I was weighing I think I maybe
got a little bit less out of the program
I also you know I wasn't necessarily
interested in going to just any Business
School and I think for me I really had
my heart set on Stanford and so I think
although it was really helpful to go
through that kind of program and explore
a bunch of different programs I think
for me I I knew I wanted to come here
and I I wasn't sure if Business School
was the right thing you know I can't was
coming most recently from the social
sector and so I think it was a great
network and a great experience but I
think without it it also is possible to
apply and get to school and making that
work in community here as well yeah so
to clarify what MLT is it is management
leadership for tomorrow it's essentially
a program that's geared at filling the
pipeline from the CEO suite the the C
suite all the way down to entry into
college and this specific program is is
the MBA prep so what that's one of the
lines the pipelines in there
so what MLT specifically does is geared
at
in Americans Hispanics and Native
Americans again to fill that pipeline of
traditionally underrepresented
minorities in the space and so it's just
a coaching program you have a cohort as
Ruth mentioned is really just a support
system for about a year before business
school starts so really understanding
the process knowing what it takes to get
in knowing you know what what your
profile needs to be and you get coaching
and so it's essentially a great program
and highly recommend it feel free to
look it up I also did MLT and for me I
think similar to Ruth what she mentioned
is my cohort was very instrumental and
even me coming to Stanford I already
knew a ton of people who had gotten in
round one I plowed applied round two so
it was great just having people who I
knew look like me who I had met who were
extraordinary people but also people
that you know I've shared a drink with
or gotten to lunch with actually having
someone that I knew went to Stanford I
think prior to MLT I didn't know anybody
that went to Stanford so it just made it
a still aspirational but an achievable
concept for me
let's stick on applications I love this
question
were you ever scared at any point in
time of applying and is the school just
full of nerds to be in there it is nerd
nation yeah sure I think I I think
scared is an interesting word I think
for me it was always it always felt like
and you couldn't guarantee you're gonna
get in and then I think that's true for
every business school and I think
perhaps especially true for Stanford and
so I think for me it was always a one is
is Business School right for me
especially where I'm at now and my
journey is this the best step to take
and then to you know is this you know
it's such a time investment to apply
it's like almost it felt like a
different job outside of my regular job
and
had to get support from mentors and
advisors and it was like I'm gonna go
through this I want to make sure I'm
putting there my time in the right place
and so I think it was scary in that
sense it was scary to invest so much
time into something that didn't feel for
sure and then also I wasn't sure and so
a lot of those uncertainties were at
play are we all nerds that I don't I
don't know how to answer that I
definitely would aspire to be a nerd I I
enjoy the classes a lot and then love
learning and if that makes me a nerd
then I guess there am for me I wasn't
scared because I really was applying to
Stanford blind in a lot of ways similar
to format it I didn't really know people
that went to Stanford I knew one person
that went to Stanford before I got in
and I know that there are people who
might have known known dozens of people
just based on people that worked with
them or friends or family members and
things like that so I don't even think I
knew enough to be scared um to be honest
with you guys but I think that I really
just applied on my best foot and I think
we might get into some questions about
when I'm when is it right to apply and
things like that but I applied knowing
that this is the best I have to offer
and thankfully it was it was good enough
so I'm super super happy about that
in terms of being a nerd here and all we
all nerds actually think what I've
noticed yet Stanford is that people
really aspire to to improve themselves
intellectually and that it has become
sort of currency one of the different
currencies and I don't actually don't
think that that's a bad thing because in
terms of having fun like fun is in you
so if you can't have fun and you're not
a nerd that could be possible too so I
don't think that and I think that being
a nerd might be a is actually a good
thing personally but that doesn't take
away from having an amazingly fun and
amazingly great experience so that's how
I see it I think that's well said I mean
I think exactly what you said people
here have done amazing things or
aspiring to do amazing things I would
consider people aspirational but you
know that also sometimes
is correlated with wanting to read a
book and maybe yeah but equally we have
a lot of fun I think if you want to be
social there's something oh yeah every
single day I think I've gotten myself
caught into that sometimes yeah
sometimes I have to just all back in
read a [ __ ] yeah I some Netflix can you
can just to calm down but I think the
school is you'll find is over 400
students in one grade so once you kind
of combine all the all the programs you
have over eight eight hundred people
just naturally eight hundred people
you're gonna have a range of what people
do want to do and what they don't want
to do so I actually consider even the
diversity and people's experiences and
what they want to do and even on the
nerd scale I say there's a diversity
yeah yeah for those who do want to come
and nerd out though like there's
definitely opportunity that you can be
super focused on academics you can nerd
out in terms of like one of my favorite
groups is this like political group we
come together and discuss politics once
a month last this past month was
superheated some months it's a little
more chill but that sort of thing like
that's a community that I considered we
all nerd out on different facts like
that so different ways to be a nerd and
different ways to engage in the
community this might be a good time to
you know to ask or to tell people kind
of your your favorite activities I think
you mentioned that or clubs I can start
one of my favorite clubs is the wine
club just because it's so amazing we
have Somali a so speaking a little bit
of nerdy but in the wine sense um you
know they come they do tastings we talk
about the notes and the tannins and all
that and we've had especially with Napa
Valley be even right up the road we've
had special guests come in special
wineries coming and teach us and and be
a little bit more educated in the wine
space so that's one of my favorites I
like so many favorites is really hard to
I'm sure we'll talk about the BBS later
a later so we can put that aside I love
the social entrepreneurship community so
the social innovation there's a club
there's the Center for social innovation
there's just like a ton of pieces and
ways to plug in to that community and
they've not only been super helpful and
starting something of my own but also in
just providing support
and guidance and just folks to talk
about different things and so social
entrepreneurship kind of runs the gamut
and social innovation runs the gamut but
getting to learn from other students
experience has been super valuable to me
as well as the advisors and the mentors
and like venture studio you can go work
on your idea they're just I should stop
talking because I could go on forever
I think one of my favorite activities
here is traveling and and the funny
thing is at the GSB traveling can mean a
ton of things so it can mean going to
Yellowstone and spending a weekend
hiking and and and and with your and
with people that you know you've gotten
to know or it can be getting an academic
experience in another country which we
call gscs here or it can be going to
Indonesia and making your own cultural
and academic experience or doing that in
Cuba so I love how just very textured
our traveling experiences are here you
can have a great time where you do
nothing or you you know you have a lot
of alcohol or you can have a really
great learning experience and it's not
just because the school mandates is
because people have this drive to really
immerse themselves in different cultures
and in different experiences and and
humbly get to know those cultures and
experiences so in terms of me all the
places that I've been to with my with my
Stanford whether friends or classmates
for the purpose of a fourth purpose of
the school or for the purpose of just
like us planning a trip I've had just
amazing an amazing time and even in the
the times that are not specifically
learning experiences I've still learned
something because I got to know my
classmates a little bit better because
we were in the middle of Cuba together
or I got to know what business is like
in Brazil and what the future of tech in
Brazil is gonna look like in the next 10
years yeah and I think your point about
the International component too we do
have a big international presence here
at Stanford and so that also helps to is
you get to go to your classmates home
country yeah Mexico and so Mexico and
then even some South Korea Lebanon
it's all over yeah all over the Bob way
yeah so that's also a really cool
experience to is there doesn't have to
be an official school sponsored event
but through your classmates you can
still get that experience matters Hauser
and those have been some of the best
experiences here at Stanford for me so
another question is Stanford has an
exceptionally diverse class look at that
transition how is it being a person of
color at the GSB considering the
environment at other top schools and low
percentages in the minority communities
mm-hmm for me I would say that being a
minority here in terms of me having the
identity of being African but also
considering myself black Merrigan I
think that it is different from other
schools from other schools that have
much larger classes just because of
numbers so if you have like a 400
student class versus a 900 student class
obviously there will be more or
hopefully say there's more there will be
more people of color numbers from a
numbers perspective but what I love
about this this community is that
because we are smaller we have so many
more opportunities to get to know each
other and in a lot of ways we feel like
we're in the trenches together in terms
of continuing to create more access for
those coming after us
I will say that were it makes you feel
like you have you are more of an agent
of change rather than more of a cog in
the process I don't know if that's the
right phrase and I also love the fact
that in terms of I'll speak within the
black community where so there's so many
different experiences within that
community I've never met a diverse group
of black people like I've met at
Stanford and I love that because I get
to see what life is like if you are from
the Midwest or what life is like if
you're from the Upper East Side of New
York or where life is like if you're
from Johannesburg South Africa you know
and people get to understand what my
life was like too so so I love that in
terms of now looking outward for the
rest of our classmates I will say that
I've also never met a more set of
intrigue
people who genuinely want to know what
my experience is as a black woman and
who want to come into that with with
humility as well as just a sense of
wanting to learn what my life is like
and hopefully wanting to connect with me
in that way and so that's also something
that I've seen in a lot of my classmates
and I appreciate from a lot of my
classmates as well yeah yeah I think
kind of echoing what you're saying Ruth
coming to the GSB and being a woman of
color being a black woman I think is
going to be colored by your experience
as part of that so I came I went to a
predominantly white undergraduate
institution you know have operated in a
business world which isn't as diverse as
I would like it to be and I think you
know coming to Stanford was no different
than those experiences and if anything I
found the community community to be
focused on increasing diversity equity
and inclusion here so I'm on the
Diversity Committee it's a hugely
diverse group of students who are like
we're out here just like pushing even
more advancement and in terms of what
experiences could be like for students
of color for students of historically
underrepresented backgrounds for
students who are in different minority
groups or hold different identities and
so to me that's kind of part of my way
of one doing something that I care
deeply about something that affects me
it's also related to the Social Venture
I'm working on and so getting to work in
a bunch of different ways on that has
been really powerful and working with
the administration working with other
student leaders on campus has been
really fun and rewarding I think
personally like I would echo the black
community at Stanford super diverse I
think the whole community as a person I
think I already mentioned talk but one
of the things I loved about that is it
exposes even though you know this person
might appear a certain way and you might
assume different identities or
experiences to them and prescribe that I
think what is amazing about Stanford is
people will surprise you what they've
been through what they've been what
they've overcome and that's true across
all backgrounds and so I think in many
ways I feel very much one of so many
different stories and it's in this
larger community and I think my
experience is one that people seek out
and I seek out learning about others too
so that's been good yeah and I would
also add that I think being
presidents of the BBS a also provides a
unique opportunity yeah so whether
that's working with administration on
our diversity initiatives whether that
was someone tapping me on the shoulder
to do some moderating work yesterday
evening I think we are in a very visible
position both pun intended and not and
that allows us to get involved and be
part of conversations and have a seat at
the tables I think that's important too
all right so I think speaking of
inclusion this is this is I think a
really important question
so someone mentioned they really want to
apply to the MBA program but the cost of
the program is a really big hurdle was
that also concerned for either of you
and just Stanford offer any financial
support first before they jump in I will
say I encourage you to go to our
financial aid on our website there's
some information there and financial aid
as I'm sure this person asked is a very
personal situation so take what we say
you know with with the right lens for
yourself but if you do reach out to
financial aid they will give you more
specifics but if you guys don't mind
sharing kind of personally for you how
you thought about it
yeah I think definitely the the cost of
attending business school is one of the
hurdles for me to make get over mentally
and not only applying but it you know
once getting in if Business School was
right for me
it's super hard decision and like the
meta that super personal as well I what
I can say is that since coming to the
GSB I felt like I'm getting what I you
know I'm paying for in many ways and
more than I could have imagined and I
think you know starting this
organization starting this venture
meeting these people getting to do these
new experiences that are so much more
kind of scope expanding in terms of how
I saw my life what I saw is possible for
myself what what careers exist so like
what is it what is what could be has
been such a valuable part of the
experience that I can't necessarily put
like a tangible like this cost that
amount and I'm
therefore it's a return on my investment
but I can say that you know you that's
something you're gonna have to decide
individually for yourself but have found
my time here to be so valuable already
we're only at kind of the beginning of
our spring quarter of first year at
least Ruth and I and so you know happy
to to talk more about that one-on-one
but I think it's something you're gonna
have to think deeply about for yourself
yeah I think for me too coming I'm very
attentive very risk-averse so I was
thinking about you know what how would I
pay this off and and things like that
but I think even as a risk-averse person
it was very clear to see that the ROI
here was going to was going to be high I
think for me again everybody is gonna
have a different financial aid sort of
offer if and when you do when you do get
into the school based on different
scholarships that the school offers and
and things like that but but I will say
that even coming here and just expanding
my mind as to what my financial future
can even look like based on my different
classmates experiences and and what I've
learned from different professors has
made the cost seem so myopic it makes me
feel like I thought so myopically about
him whereas I'm like actually this is
how I should even envision what my
financial future should look like and
this is how small this cost is compared
to that so I would even encourage people
not to necessarily regardless of what
school you're applying not to
necessarily see this thing as a okay
once I graduate school I'm gonna have to
be paying off my loans for the next two
years because or the next five years or
ten years because you know I'm probably
gonna be making this much definitely
really just understand that your your
financial future really is going really
is more expansive than probably most
people think it is and this can be a
really small cost if you really take
advantage of really a lot of
opportunities that you have just because
you would have the Stanford brand on
your name throughout your career
literally for the rest of your career
yeah I will add that for folks who are
thinking about going into nonprofit or
social sector
any sort of perhaps less lucrative
career there is a loan forgiveness
program that you should look into it's
something that was a huge part of my
deciding to come knowing that if I
wanted to go back and work at an
education on profit or do something in
that space you know the cost actually is
perhaps prohibitive but with loan
forgiveness it became a lot more
reasonable and feasible for me it's at
least personally yeah and the school
also offers to at least this point
opportunities for people who want to go
into the social sector right after
school
you know offers different sorts of
fellowships which again like for Metta
said you guys can look online for but
yeah three point so I'm not gonna
respond to that question because there
there's a special area that's going on
I'm gonna try to get to all these
questions before we're out of time so at
least I'm gonna direct this to you so as
someone coming from the social sector
how have you viewed the business school
experience and then for someone who's
interested in the social social sector
what do you say is the value of business
school yeah and so I think coming
directly from k-12 education which is
extremely progressive I was a little
taken aback getting into the business
school realm and having people say
things like fiduciary responsibilities
and I was like but but the kids you know
but I think it has what about the kids
but I think it has been super valuable
um I think there's classes like
financial modelling which is just skills
that are important to know accounting
was like a struggle at the beginning but
I think it is important to build that
kind of business acumen whether you're
in the social sector or the private
sector I think there is you know I think
having that joint degree and being in
masters in education is also a nice
pairing personally for me um you know
one of my ed classes we were like
sitting on the floor like legs crossed
there was like a fire on like the
projector you know what I mean so
different vibes but I also think that
vibe can be found in the business school
and so choosing classes like social
ventures practicum or philanthropy
there's just like a ton of that sort of
energy in the community and so I think
although you might come here and be like
everyone's gonna be doing like
consulting and Finance like that's not
true and in fact so many people talk
about the impact they want to have and
what that means in whatever career
they're pursuing so yeah yeah yeah I
definitely heard that I think the other
thing too
really unique about Stanford that you
alluded to is that there's so many
social related classes yes and then I
know one of my good friends is also a
tool in the education program and he
said that one of those classes on just
like the thought process of instituting
education reform and coupling that with
policy in the business school was a way
that he even thought about that
so I'd say get creative too yeah on how
you think about the social sector and
what skills on both sides so the private
and the public sector what you can do
there yeah all right
hmm let's move on so I think related on
mentality and and and mindset I think
this is a good one too how is the MBA
program transformed your perspective on
the issues you seek to tackle as a
leader in your field and have your
interactions with other MBA students
made you consider collaborating across
fields in the near future yeah I think
for me I think for me in terms of the
type of leader that I want to be I think
coming from a very corporate corporate
role before the before the NBA made me
think of a leader as kind of had this
profile of what a leader look like and
you had to say certain things and you
had to act a certain way and you
couldn't be vulnerable in a B C or D way
whereas here we're literally turning the
definition of what a leader is upside
down and vulnerability is is shown as a
sign of strength and being able to be
honest about what type of impact you
want to have is not a bad thing and it's
not just about the bottom line I think I
don't even think I've ever heard that
actually
in terms of what people would consider a
successful run of any sort of business
or initiative and so for me knowing what
I want to do in knowing the type of
impact that I want to have in Africa I
think that what what I've learned is
that it doesn't have to be one way the
awesome thing is for example I'm taking
a class right now in our design school
which which is an awesome school by the
way I'm called design thinking studio
and I'm seeing how the problems that I
want to solve even don't have to be
through through tech which a lot of
people would be surprised about coming
to Stanford they probably think that
we're super tech focus and
only tech everything is tech but we're
really think we're really like breaking
things down to the bare minimum
literally using our hands to build
things and and and figure out how can we
solve a world problem from so many
different ways in my class alone I'm
working with the student from the
medical school somebody from School of
Education somebody from the law school
right we're all working on one project
together and so I'm learning different
things from how do I solve this problem
through policy how do I solve it through
through journalism I think there's so
many different ways to think about
solving problems and so many different
ways of what a leader looks like that
it's helped me to really again break
break the stereotypes of what I thought
I had the path I thought I had to go and
really understand that there's so many
different innovative ways to solve
different problems and there's so many
ways to do that as me not as a profile
of somebody who I think people want to
see yeah
I'll actually take this similar question
but to build on that I think it's also
important for me I'm realizing as I'm
heading out is that leadership is a
journey not a destination and so as we
have classes like leadership
perspectives we have prominent people
coming in and yeah it's just a they give
an intro and then they just stop and we
just get to ask them questions and
thinking about Chairman's of Microsoft
yeah and all these other places just the
ability to ask questions like how do you
manage your career how do you manage
your career a dual career how do you you
know it's it's been amazing and so
really recognizing that even people at
the top of the mountain are still
working on the next thing for themselves
the similar question here is people of
color face unique challenges in the
workforce would you say the GSB gave you
the tools to navigate the unique
challenges people of color face in the
modern workplace
so I'll take that I think the answer is
yes as we mentioned you know through BBS
a we get to have some of these you know
tough conversations and we get to talk
what's what is it like being a black
woman and we get to talk with our male
counterparts about here are some of the
unique challenges that we we face that
maybe you guys aren't really as in tune
with I think the other thing that
Stanford has taught me is you know I
think using my voice and really feeling
comfortable with my truth whether that's
through
talk whether that's through leadership
labs actually getting the feedback that
I think sometimes as an african-american
getting the feedback that you're
articulate can be a little at but then I
actually realize because one of my
classmates is like nofa betta you're
actually very are above the average and
I was like okay so for the first time
actually realizing okay this is what
this looks like so I think it's really
important to recognize that you're
constantly getting feedback and through
that feedback there is that
self-reflection yeah and recognizing
that okay here's how I land on other
people or present to other people and
therefore here's what I can do as a
business leader to either double down on
that or I need to adjust some of my
behavior to seem more warm and more
welcoming or whatever that may be so I
don't think there's like if there wasn't
a class I'm like how to be a black
leader but through these experiences and
recognizing and reflecting I think has
allowed me to recognize there are
challenges and having conversations with
classmates having the courage to speak
up there's a you know there is a way to
address you know some things like hey
have you recognized that this makes me
feel this way when you say this just
really having the courage to speak up
and then kind of stand in my own truth I
think is important - yeah there is a
class of the leadership from diverse
perspectives I'm gonna take it in the
fall - I'm excited that I am building
diverse organizations so there are some
diversity related ones okay so this is
gonna be a rapid one for you guys um
let's talk about the academic experience
what's the curriculum like maybe high
level case studies versus experiential
versus lecture they're different there's
so many different ways to learn here
which I think are awesome so we do have
classes that you know you read a case
each week and you kind of discuss it we
have classes where each week is your you
are getting I'm taking a finance class
for example right now and it's awesome I
love my class so essentially it feels
like I have two professors who really it
feels like they write a script the night
before every night and like feed off of
each other from their finance and so
they they
make they helped me learn finance in a
way that I've never learned it before
it's not about it's not about just
equations it's about actually
understanding why things happen and and
really when I'm when I'm paying
attention in the class I actually can
apply it to whatever I'll be doing in
the future and then they bring in
professionals from CFOs of Fortune 500
companies who we can really ask
questions deep and meaningful and
applicable questions too so I'll let you
guys talk about your experiences but
there's so many different ways to learn
here it's pretty awesome yeah there is
like a core curriculum around management
foundations which as the title says it's
foundational courses in business yeah
but I think Ruth alluded to this earlier
and there's classes that you've taken
the Business School you can take classes
across the street one of my favorite
classes was across the street is and
other programs at Stanford when my
favorite classes was in the engineering
school it's called the lean launchpad
it's a bunch of folks from all different
schools coming together to like explore
product market fit it's taught by a
bunch of folks in VC they bring in
mentors from industry so that was a
great class that's a super experiential
on but I mean even at the business
school I'm in a class that's all about
social ventures practical I mentioned it
earlier but we essentially go through
what is needed in a business plan and
each class is focused on one piece of
that they bring in leaders who have
actually gone through that class and are
now leading social ventures so someone
came in from I think it was in Bob Way
last week someone was calling in from
like Pakistan or something you know what
I mean it was like a lot of different
people doing different things which is
cool and so lots of group projects lots
of different ways to learn and I think
that's good since everyone learns
differently yeah yeah cool I know
there's still some questions on here and
career and professional development so
I'm just gonna go ahead and take those
so there's a question on structured
mentorship programs and opportunities I
would say it's not structured there are
some things that we have with the Career
Management Center but the Career
Management Center I also sit on that
committee that has programs available to
you if you're trying to transition from
social sector to consulting there's a
consulting Club we also have a finance
and investments Club we have various
clubs that take on essentially the the
mentorship role and then when you start
at Stanford you'll have a fellow and
arbuckle fellow who's a sec
year there's also there to help coach
you as well so that's an opportunity um
Oh question for the president what's
next for you after the GSB I'll take
that so for me I will be moving to
Chicago and working at the Boston
Consulting Group so I get I get a nice
little break so I'll probably do some
travel and oh okay so last question for
everyone did you pay a visit to campus
before applying and if so was the visit
worth it and then when would you
recommend someone visit and yeah so like
I said my application process was a
little bit different I didn't know a ton
of people before applying I did visit
Stanford but I didn't even tell
administration what my name was
because at that point I didn't feel like
saying who I was was gonna move the
needle and and I think that that that
played out as I thought it would
I think visiting the Stanford campus
campus while it is important I do think
that you should have a reason as to why
you're visiting if you really need to be
here I do think the pictures do a great
justice and California is what people
say it is so if you if you are for
example apply from a different country
don't feel like you're at a loss because
you can't be physically on the campus
before you apply but I will definitely
say that if you apply and you do get in
definitely obviously visit the campus
for admin weekend to just get to see how
the vibe is before you before you
actually come so I my application
process was very long I most recently
was in the Bay Area before school but
also was in New York before that and so
I visited campus when I was in New York
I went I came for the diverse like
perspectives day which i think is coming
up for black students so historically
underrepresented students and that was
actually a really great event I loved
meeting other folks who are applying
hearing different backgrounds I also
loved the alumni who came back and
talked about their experience at the GSB
met like admissions folks that was
helpful for me and kind of building this
in is what Stanford would be and then
when I lived in the Bay it was easy to
come down and check out campus again
yeah I also visited
sorry to interrupt you but we had what I
did get in I came for admin weekend
which was also the conference weekend
which which were holding this year on
May 10th and 11th yeah and so it was an
amazing experience for me because I
think the the one of the keynote
speakers that day was the person who
heads of all of Beyonce's casual so it
was such a great experience to meet so
many amazing professionals so many
amazing alumni from decades to recently
so many amazing perspectives and current
students so that was a really great
weekend for me and that's where also
meta meta I also met a lot of people who
are my classmates now yeah so quick plug
for that if you go to BBS a conference
com
you can find all the information there
also will be prospective students day
portion on the 10th so look for all that
information on our website and also as
mentioned diversity day will be on the
18th and we'll also have kind of a deep
dive with professors and you'll probably
see us yeah in much many more of the
current students as well yeah alright so
we're out of time and so I would love to
give you guys like 10 seconds before we
go to say any final words advice for
people thinking and applying to Stanford
MBA I would say that Stanford is and can
be for you whatever your passions are
whatever you aspire to you can come here
and make that reality it's a beautiful
place where I've never felt like I could
do whatever I wanted to until I came to
Stanford and I think it's partially
because of the community because of the
resources but I hope to see you here on
campus soon yeah I would definitely say
Stanford is a one-of-a-kind place where
you get an experience that can only be
the best thing for you and I would
definitely say that in terms of
relationships not just with students but
with professors with companies in the
area it's definitely been a great value
add in my life so I would encourage you
guys to apply and yes hopefully see you
guys next fall yeah you won't see me
because I might come back to campus
great thank you both and thank you guys
for joining us today and your thoughtful
questions again we encourage you to
reach out admissions can put you in
contact with anybody in the BBS a if you
do have any more specific questions that
we didn't answer and we look forward to
seeing you for the conference or
diversity day the weekend of the 10th or
the 18th thank you thank you thank you
[Music]